Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is not an episode about a paper, but
it's about the series itself.
There are some minor changes coming, and I
am trying my very best to make it as enjoyable
as possible to you, so I would really like
to hear your opinion on an issue.
Many of our episodes are on new topics where
I am trying my best to cover the basics so
that the scope of a new research work can
be understood clearly.
However, as we are continuing our journey
deeper into the depths of state of the art
research, it inevitably happens that we have
to build on already existing knowledge from
earlier episodes.
The big question is, how we should handle
such cases.
For instance, in the case of a neural network
paper, the solution we went for so far was
having a quick recap for what a neural network
is.
We can either have this recap in every episode
about for instance, neural networks, fluid
simulations or photorealistic rendering and
be insidiously annoying to our seasoned Fellow
Scholars who know it all.
Or, we don't talk about the preliminaries
to cater to the more seasoned Fellow Scholars
out there, at the expense new people who are
locked out of the conversation, as they may
be watching their very first episode of Two
Minute Papers.
So the goal is clear, I'd like the episodes
to be as easily understandable as possible,
but while keeping the narrative intact so
that every term I use is explained in the
episode.
First, I was thinking about handing out a
so called "dictionary" in the video description
box where all of these terms would be explained
briefly.
At first, this sounded like a good idea, but
most people new to the series would likely
not know about it, and for them, the fact
that these episodes are not self-contained
anymore would perhaps be confusing, or even
worse, repulsive.
The next idea was that, perhaps, instead of
re-explaining these terms over and over again,
we could add an overlay text in the video
for them.
The more seasoned Fellow Scholars won't be
held up because they know what a Lagrangian
fluid simulation is, but someone new to the
series could also catch up easily just by
reading a line of text that pops up.
I think this one would be a formidable solution.
I would love to know your opinion on these
possible solutions, I personally think that
the overlay text is the best, but who knows,
maybe a better idea gets raised.
Please make sure to let me know below in the
comments section whether you have started
watching Two Minute Papers recently or maybe
you're a seasoned Fellow Scholar, and how
you feel about the issue.
Have you ever encountered terms that you didn't
understand?
Or was it the opposite, am I beating a dead
horse with re-explaining all this simple stuff?
I'd like to make these episodes the best I
possibly can so that seasoned Fellow Scholars
and people new to the show alike can marvel
at the wonders of research.
All feedback is welcome and please make sure
to leave a comment so I can better understand
how you feel about this issue and what would
make you happier.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!